yeah why do you guys think that women
are becoming masculine nowadays because
men are becoming feminine yeah
no honestly you're you know it's I put a
lot of blame on on men for a lot of the
stuff that you know even even men men
complain about right
um really I feel like it started with
the women yeah look some of it does but
men men have created certain conditions
on a big level right right okay look how
many people how many people are raised
by how many millions of people in
Western Society now are raised by single
mothers right but why
oftentimes because men are not playing
their role that exists that's that's a
big thing but then you've oh you've got
an imbalance right you've got both men
and women are being raised primarily
just by women and the masculine role is
missing and that manifests differently
for both for for boys and girls as they
grow into as they grow into men and
women and as a woman it's naturally if
if a man is not present there you've now
got to play both you've got to play both
roles so
what no you don't well I mean I was a
single parent right now that's that's
this is a lie that the women say this
okay what I mean is you you are
it's a it's a typically raising a child
is a two-person job you have the father
you have the mother and in the absence
of a father whether that is through
death or through absence or through
whatever the reason
what I mean what I mean by play both
roles is you've got one person
doing a two-person
we're in control of birth so we pick who
gets born so it's our own fault like
that's why I say it starts with the
women I don't because and like and on
top of that like it's the development of
birth control I feel like the
development yeah
you're right I would say if I was to put
it on men I would say it's because men
did all that men men are the ones who
who made those laws even men's men are
the ones who came up with no fault
divorce men are the ones who come up
with so you know I can't just
I know I know it's popular to kind of
put it all on one gender
um and I think that you know there's
there there's both the fault but if I
look at it ultimately you know men men
have played a massive role I'm not
saying every single man of course not
right but men in general have played a a
massive role in this oftentimes by not
stepping into their proper masculine
roles and leaving it for
women to pick up the what do you mean
can you explain that more what I mean is
you know if I get a woman pregnant right
okay and
I can step up and do what I'm supposed
to do morally ethically
family socially cultural like I'm I'm
supposed to step up into that right and
and I and I choose not to I choose to
abandon I choose to leave her to fend
for herself and deal with that or what
maybe maybe I'm sending a check every
you know right then
that's that's my bet and by the way and
this is and this is happening to the
tune of millions right right and I I
agree with you but I'm sure you're so
familiar with the red pill you know
women women are the ones that leave we
leave 70 to 80 of the time ninety
percent of our college education so so
like while while there are two sides to
it like and we we could talk about the
30 like that why wouldn't you start with
the 70 what women are the ones I think I
think we're talking about two different
situations right so we're talking well
you you just so the the male abandonment
tends to happen at a relatively early
stage uh-huh right so if the child is
born and the child is not even born yet
and the dude disappears slips out the
picture and then and then you're talking
about there's actually a relationship or
a marriage and then the woman breaks
away from that yeah both I I would say
women leave relationships more too and
in the first situation like we know when
we're ovulating so I just feel like if
we're in control of birth like that's on
us and and a lot of times girls will
like try to make a guy that's not a
husband into a husband and they'll try
to like get pregnant and keep the kid
like and so so it's like I'm not gonna
put that on the men when you knew who he
was yeah I put it on both okay okay I
put it on both I'm not gonna let men off
the hook here right just like I don't I
wouldn't let women off the hook if
someone was trying to put this all on
men I'd be like no no you can't let
women off the hook if also someone's
trying to put it all on on a woman I'll
be like well you can't let men off the
hook right there's millions and millions
of men out there who are not doing what
they're supposed to be doing
as a single parent
I think that
I know he's saying that many invented
the pill
but somebody must have invented cyan
eyes or poison nobody make them take it
right so just because somebody's making
something
it don't mean that oh you can go ahead
and take it and when it comes to single
parents
you can understand you saying
I've only got one child single parent
one child
but when you get women having free four
five six seven children eight I think
there's some out there nine that was
still looking for dates sometimes by
nine different fathers can't put it all
on demand I'll say yeah the first one
yeah because
a lot of men
don't ask to be fathers
they don't ask to be fathers my son's
dad never asked to be a father actually
just I was on the pill it was an
accident I actually discussed it with
him
and even though he agreed that I have
the child
I was
I knew that if I had to raise him on my
own I did because he never asked for him
and I don't believe in abortion
so as far as I'm concerned
single parent says no excuse even if the
father's not there there's plenty of
really good Role Models out there male
role models you know you've got the
grandfathers you've got the uncles
you've got the really good friends
and then you should be able to do that
with a child without expecting anything
my son is 36 years old I think in all
his life I took 100 pounds from his dad
that's what I asked for 100 pound for
his dad
and when they say that oh the government
supports him and everything and I
remember at the time I was studying and
they said oh you know you get extra
money for being a single parent but they
want to know who the dad is and I said
nope take your money
take your money it's not a good
influence so my son take your money I'll
do it on my own but he always had good
Role Models yes and that's important and
that's important too many they make too
many single parents make it look so hard
you know it's hard when you don't keep
on it's hard when you don't have to shut
your legs when you don't know how to
shut your legs and you don't know how to
get birth control of course it's going
to be hard now bearing in mind there's
no excuses I'm the exception to every
rule there is out there I'm the
exception
any situation I can say I'm the
exception to everything so I'm a rarity
but I know a lot of single parents and
either for that was some of them that
friends of mine because I was a
hard-working person I can afford for
them to have children and they're not
working but I couldn't afford for me to
have any more yes because I was hard
working so I can't I will say put it on
the men because at the end of the day
yeah you can say put a condom you think
that after getting pregnant on the pill
that I just relied on the pill I just
relied on the condom I was using
everything there was you name it even if
I had the injection and they said it's
90 I'm still using a condom even if I
was on the pill I'm still using a condom
so it's gotta be down to the women yeah
because at the end of the day
a single parent with more than one child
for the same person I can understand
that but a single parent with loads of
little
I was gonna say little nigglets
are saying that in my head yeah
what was it it's not noses yeah
but the little babies yeah and you've
got loads of them running around I
remember I grew up with a girl and and
she was like the black version of
Angelina Jolie I saw her and every
single nationality you see she slept
with maybe to try them out
you know and they were oh she never had
two kids that resembled each other and
they were all hers so she didn't yeah
and at the end of the day and you're
saying that
I'm playing deva's advocate here because
I've got one child for my son's dad yes
guess how many children he's got my
son's a second now the third guess how
many how many he he's got the father of
your child
oh boy I mean I don't know sixteen
sixteen okay wow 16. I was gonna say
eight
he's got 16. so you're trying to tell me
that all right then the first one I
think he was at school and it was a
school like there was both at school the
second one was supposed to be my son but
I knew I knew different I knew there was
another one out there that's why I said
third because he's still trying to
convince us it's a second okay
all of his children know their parents
all of his children know their dad
you're just trying to tell me that
you've got
you see a man and he's got two children
a different parents three children
how the hell you're gonna get to the
woman who's at number 16.
then he got married to somebody that
have no children for him
but you see I mean so you can't keep on
sometimes the women shut your legs it's
both I mean it takes shut your legs
because the women that go out there and
they will see a man and they think oh
he's this and this but the difference is
it's 80 90 well it's like it's most
women where it's a small percentage of
men yeah and so you're gonna say what
percentage of men that want sorry it's a
small percentage of men that women want
and so that are doing that's what I'm
saying like it's such a small percentage
So when you say it's it's the men too
it's like yeah okay it's five ten
whatever it is and then when you get the
children I'm not sure I get what's being
argued against here no who's to blame
for like you know single parents you
know it's all sometimes they say it's
all about the women that's all that is
it about the man to me to me too and I
think sometimes the single parents they
they yeah the women use it they use the
sympathy yeah to me it's to me it's
completely 50 50. like it's literally to
me it's to me it's literally 50. I don't
think it's 50 50. as a single parent I
don't think it's 50 50. I don't I mean
if I go out there and I father 16 kids
I don't know why I would be absolved
yeah of the fact that I've chosen to go
out there we have more control like we
can be out we you can get an IUD it's 99
effective you don't have that control
we do we do do a pretty strong extent
it's not but the women don't want to get
pregnant like if you want like I'm not
saying like like some you know I mean if
if I wanted to have 16 kids I could have
16 kids
why are women choosing to have 16 Shoes
all right then some of them have got
five children I could even just be just
like if I were a snake I could even be
completely deceptive about it like oh
I've got 14 no he wasn't I'm saying you
could as a man yeah as a cat you could I
could have you could have 12 kids out
there and go and have a 13th with
another she's not even aware about the
of the other 12 or whatever you can say
oh whatever you know even promise oh you
know we're gonna get we're going to do
this unbelievable
dude there's some dudes in this
situation they were all aware no even
girls girl they know and this is what
irritates me is they'll they'll act like
they don't know they might not know that
like maybe 13 kids they might not know
but you know when a dude is sleeping
around you do and I don't believe it for
a second when these girls say oh I
didn't know I found out the difference
between sleeping around and fathering or
just having a ton of kids I mean to me
it's to me it's a 50 50 thing some of
them I mean you have like five minutes
um because and what makes it worse is
that they choose the bad men and then
they're proud of it at the time and then
when it doesn't work they blame them in
you know either woman come up to me
Woolworths isn't there anymore but she
came up to me with a baby and said he's
got a boy now
say he's and I thought you already had
two girls
you're not with him
and you're gonna approach me to say that
he's got a son because I I'm the only
one with one and I thought to myself why
would you do that why would you even go
there and have more children
you know but all that all the women knew
all the women knew that he had all these
children they always they always know
they always know and then they blame him
oh knows as well like I don't understand
why we are absorbing all responsibility
from the man he's had children
would you have a chance
he can control that as well yeah make
sure she's on the pill if she lies too
different I was on the pill yeah but
that's different because you were on the
pill but it's like you literally you you
know that some you're having sex could
potentially have a child yes you know
that yes you didn't do anything to make
sure she stops this happening how can
you then have no responsibility I'm not
I'm not disagree like yes men men have a
part to play but I just think it's more
on the women because we have control we
are in control of birth if you if you
get pregnant you can get an abortion men
have no say in that so until that's
equal I can't say we're in equally at
fault
birth control what men have won and
we're also in control of the people that
we sleep with you can require they wear
a condom well that's even misogynistic
not development no no no not developing
a lot of birth control for men when men
are having no trouble these women that's
misogynistic okay they've tried but it
led to a lot of men being sterilized so
it's it's not massaging there's a new
one they're working at that's it's
that's just a simple biological equation
because men produce millions of sperm
every day women produce one egg per
month it's easier to control one egg
than it is millions and millions of
sperm so that that's just a biological
function that's why it's like that way
it's not because you know scientists are
mean and misogynistic and want to kind
of put it all on women it's just that
it's it's easier that way it's just it's
kind of you know you just got a barrier
you can just have a barrier
um but it's just a tough thing to work
out awesome yeah when it comes to women
we know we know the days that
we can get pregnant we can be a little
bit more risque with it and be like okay
I may not have to take the pill of the
day I may not have to go get a plan B we
know when the peak time for us to get
pregnant that's why I think it'd be more
so on the women than the men I'm not
giving off I'm gonna I'm gonna be maybe
maybe I'm just gonna be like old school
here but look we all we all know how
babies are made man woman we we all know
how this process works
um so number one I you know some people
won't like me saying this but I don't
think you should be having sex with
people who you're mortified with the
concept of having a child with exactly
right like if the thought of having a
child with that person is going to be
like the end the end of the world or
some or then maybe you shouldn't be and
this goes for I'm saying this for men
too all right I'm saying this for men
too if the thought of that woman getting
pregnant by you is makes you want to run
to the hills maybe bro you should you
know be be careful there
um so you know these conversations
sometimes frustrate me because it's like
it's kind of you know it's like look
let's just let's just be mature be
mature about it and make good decisions
and don't be don't be Reckless we have
all there's different options out there
um
everyone knows anyone who knows me knows
I'm straight up pro-life I don't think
that executing the baby is the uh is is
the way forward at all morally
um but there are many things you can do
to prevent that and not get to that
stage
um so I think I think I think I don't
want to let men off the hook on this at
all because
we both both sexes need to just be
responsible and sensible with this like
sex is not I know that modern society
wants to push out and indoctrinate
everyone with this message that it's
just you know some completely random
inconsequential fun activity like Ping
Pong or going to the you know or
whatever but it's like it's got very
serious potential lifelong ramifications
um and it's how we all got here right
it's like it's a it's a major thing and
with something that's that has can have
such potential ramifications you know
people should not treat it so carelessly
I think that's the truth of it it
shouldn't be treated so carelessly and
recklessly and I think if you know and
and by the way people always knew this
like this isn't something new I'm not
saying something new here people knew
this forever which is why there were
certain behaviors that were frowned upon
or promoted and so on and so forth it's
not just trying to be mean to everyone
or to cramp cramp down on their Liberty
um it's like well children are up the
product of this yeah so I just think
that
birth control should be banned oh wow
you should be taken off the market I
agree okay
I told you that my stepdad had had 14
children yeah what did you think about
that if I say my old stepdad he's my
late stepdad had 14 children
now I said to my son's dad had 16. and
my late stepdad
at 14. interesting
the only difference is he had 13 from
one woman okay
but the and the only reason why it's
able to progress like that I believe
because of birth control
can I ask what you guys mean like that
by saying you think we have control like
and I just know women
so basically she's saying that a woman
should not be able to decide to
terminate a child
oh I see I didn't say that yeah
some traditional Catholics oh some
traditional Catholics and they'll tell
you about birth control you want to get
pregnant you have sex otherwise you know
when you're when you're ovulating and
you work around it because proper
Catholics don't believe in childcare
birth control oh I see and um my son's
my my my late stepdad
his former partner was Catholic they
have 13 children so every time they were
going to have sex they knew that if we
have it at this time or there's a
possibility because they in those days I
didn't know about ovulating you're going
to get pregnant so if every woman and
every man went out there especially the
women because they're the ones that have
to carry the baby if you knew that every
time you had sex there's a possibility
you got pregnant they believed sex
whether I stand as an atheist who
doesn't want kids
as an atheist who don't want kids I just
can't have sex or just have to work
around what I'm going to be ovulating
yes if I have normal periods that be
well you can just work your way around
it
[Music]
also because I am pro-life and I don't
want that would just lead to whatever
that would lead to a massive spike in
abortions and I think that would be okay
there are there more abortions after the
development of birth control than before
I think we're talking about things in an
Ideal World I think we're forgetting on
this self-determination you can say to
someone you shouldn't do that that is
naive well I just say as a parent of a
teenager going don't go out and do drugs
and have sex they're going to do it
anyway and that's what we like as
Society we're gonna go out and have sex
we're going to do it with you but but
the difference is with birth control you
take away the consequence and I just
think there's ramifications when you
take away the consequence if you look at
after the development of birth control
like the chart
um of when birth control was introduced
and then the divorce rate in society
it's like literally the same if we take
away birth control wouldn't what would
happen to the abortion rates exactly I
think women would be I think women would
just be more careful with who they slept
with but that's that's the pressure on
the women
okay you don't you don't think okay okay
okay
okay
you don't you don't you don't think it's
good that women should be careful with
who we sleep with yes
right right so because you said it's too
much pressure it's too much pressure to
like oh my gosh like I can't feel like
yeah I can't have sex and not being
pregnant
guys can we understand that women get
horny exactly are you guys are okay with
that concept you know like I am horny
outside of my ovulation piece
these women
were getting horny before birth control
so you shouldn't have sex no no no no no
I'm saying
I think it goes back to what zooby said
to not sleep with someone where it's
horrible if you have a child with them
of course
exactly so bad right so you said it's
too much pressure like people used to
get like pregnant back in the day before
birth control they just have a shotgun
wedding and figure it out yeah because
it wasn't the end of it the problem is
that that that that that cow that cat is
out the bag now
right so in the past in a much more
traditional and a much more religious
Society
the answer to a you know
premarital pregnancy simple answer get
married and that's still that's still a
good answer for a lot of people as far
as I'm concerned however with the way
that marriage has changed there have
been too many changes to then go and go
okay let's ban birth control now and
you've already let all these other cats
out the back to me that's just that's
just chaos I just want to see what
happens I I feel like girls would make
better decisions if there was a
consequence I don't I think you just get
a huge spike in abortions yeah I don't
think you'd get a gigantic Spike no no
we should ban that too let's ban both
okay then that's different I'm much more
in favor yeah yeah I say I don't I don't
think that I know I think that because
that that out would still exists so what
would realistically happen is people
would still just go around and prosecute
their sex or whatever so
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I would do jail time
I put them in the stocks you know what
the head in there
and they're all throwing Tomatoes
I do get what you mean by what you're
saying I think there has to be
consequences I think women I made a
comment down on this post and I got a
little backlash about I don't think it's
difficult to not get pregnant yes you're
correct yeah you're great I've never
found it difficult don't get pregnant
I've never been pregnant because I've
taken my birth control yes
um but yeah I think that in an Ideal
World birth control wouldn't need to
exist abortions wouldn't need to exist I
am a pro-abortion but
point being we're not in an Ideal World
we're in a society people that have free
will self-determinations their own
environments they will never conform to
those things it will not stop it
happening people want to have sex let's
try the time let's try to get a bunch of
horny people in this world and they're
not going to start [ __ ] because
abortion and and the like is is you know
banned okay I just I I feel like when
people like Thomas Soul always talks
about it like when people face the
consequences of their decisions they
make better decisions yeah generally
generally speaking but as we let's try
it
as we can see this is just often not the
not the case though right as we were
talking about people having you know
dozens yeah exactly well yeah but there
are a lot of times they're incentivized
to do so yeah like because like Nick
Cannon all those girls are taken care of
yeah yeah so so it's not like a con they
didn't get a consequence they got a
payout yeah yeah people are generally
going to do what Their what their
incentive advice to do you know and I
think one of the big problems we have in
in modern Western Society is that on a
lot of different issues on a lot of
things the incentives are just broken
right bad activities are incentivized
and good positive wholesome things are
often disincentivized or sometimes even
punished
um and I I don't I don't think it's good
I think you know long term that's going
to cause that's going to cause a lot of
chaos and these things are generational
and the more millions of children you
have growing up in certain circumstances
and modeling certain behaviors it's just
going to get exponentially worse
um with each generation so
you know I'm just big I'm big I'm very
big on personal responsibility and
accountability and I think it's much
better to make good decisions
up front rather than you know mess up in
all these very consequential ways and
then now you've Downstream now the line
we know everyone everyone has to clean
up the mess you know it's not just an
individual because we all Impact our
societies that we live in
that's my thought I stand by it bam
birth control okay
I actually think men are more like
irresponsible when it comes to
reproduction so I actually think it
should be the other way right more
irresponsible yeah they're more
irresponsible women are more responsible
30 of women that have had abortion no 40
of women that have had abortions have
had two or more come on yeah but they're
more men that have a lot of baby mamas
no they're not yes they are no 40 only
40 of men have even reproduced
historically
so throughout history most men like
getting to reproduce was a privilege
like women aren't most men aren't even
having sex like one out of three men
under 30 or virgin
one out of one out of three men under 30
or either virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year
all right
so that's not true
is these stats in America yeah there's
no it's here too it's in the west every
single there's no because
no it's it's okay it's because three men
under 30. there's a whole there's a
whole group of men you guys just don't
see because you guys are pretty girls
and so you're not gonna notice the guy
that's like working at Tesco involuntary
celibacy does not exist for women
the reason that women like the reason
that women think about are cheating or
think about her trash is because
literally we're all sleeping with the
same one yeah yeah because like women
women only swim the number one way
people are meeting nowadays is social
media and and you know on social media
you can be more honest I'm not social
media dating apps and so you know women
only swipe right between five to twenty
percent of the time even even if we
doubled it let's say let's say it's 40
of the time like that's still sixty
percent of men that no one like no one
wants
um yeah and but I still think the
desired men the ones in this 10
they should they should give them some
responsibility because I agree with you
they keep happening
legally Legally they do though they're
on the hook for child support like the
difference is like men actually have a
consequence where women don't because
whatever bad decision we make we're
always paid out like so if we get
pregnant we can get child support or we
can get married to the guy and take half
in a divorce
in child support only like the rich ones
like the ones literally from Tesco
they're not paying it we're women okay
women women typically don't sleep with
broke men and if they do they're usually
very no no wait let me let me let me let
me let me finish if they do they're
usually very attractive so the incentive
for the girls to get good genes from the
guy basically man you know what maybe
maybe those maybe those religions had a
point you know maybe maybe they'd work
this stuff out thousands of years ago
and we're like you know what people
should get married
and have sex in that relationship and
have children in that relationship and
that's just clean and it works
just saying you don't think it's better
now
what's better you don't think
relationships are better now
oh my oh my yeah
man there's a lot of you know I I think
as a society with a lot of things
sometimes we're we're way too quick to
assume that an old idea is a bad idea
right there are bad old ideas and
there's lots of bad new ideas as well I
think we started the first how hour and
a half of the conversation with a bad
new idea
um you know but I I think we want to
look towards what works whether whether
an idea or concept is New or Old you
know I think if something works and has
a clear function and benefit then I
generally think it's it's foolish to
throw it away or jettison it or not not
cons not at least consider it in the
context of potential
ideas and solutions because some of
these problems are age-old for thousands
and thousands of years this conversation
it wasn't happening like this on a
podcast
we're modern today people have always
been horny like people have always had
sex drives like we've always been re you
know we exist because of it literally
um but it's always like how we can
change that so
um was it Henry day because you wanted
to marry another woman so he changed the
laws to say that he can get married
again so actually it's always men men
are the problem it's not a woman
their legs closed what do you call a
woman oh come on
okay okay I just went to Carnival to do
interviews yeah you're telling me that
men are the problem when these women are
walking around in thongs in public
now you're not supposed to look sexy I
mean I you could look sexy and keep it
classy like you know there's a I think
there's a difference between like you
know a little leg a little cleavage and
like I don't know a thong
so it's your fault that you had sex with
you because you were wearing a thong uh
I'm saying that women are in control of
sex men are in control of relationships
yeah they're both in control of both no
no no control of sex too you can decide
you know what I don't want to have sex
video I think Pearl is talking about the
ultimate decision
right that ultimately it's you know
God forbid you know freaking grape
um you know ultimately
the women are The Gatekeepers of sex
yeah right
um which is why
if you want to see the up this is why
like gay dudes just you know have way
way way higher numbers of sexual because
females not involved right like it's
just dudes being dudes and they go do
their you know do their things it's very
different
um so yeah women are ultimately the The
Gatekeepers of sex and I think that when
it comes to relationships and commitment
and I think this is the point Pearl is
making men tend to be the ultimate
Gatekeepers of that of how they want
that relationship to proceed if they
want that to be okay cool like this is
exclusive or this is you know a marriage
or what what what whatever it is you
know obviously with a marriage obviously
a woman has to has to say yes to a
proposal
um but yeah I think I think the general
point there is true but I think when it
comes to the responsibility of Sex and
the responsibility of what is Downstream
from sex I put that 50 50. 90 10.
I have concerns about like letting any
sex even if it is my own my own male sex
off the hook I'll give you water a lot a
lot of a lot of bad behavior
um
[Laughter]
and I think I do think it sends the a
wrong message to young dudes out there
because I just think like oh okay well
it's on the women so I'm just gonna go
and be Reckless and spread my seed and
so am I Wild Oats in a very Reckless
Manner and then it's up to them to deal
with the messy potential consequences of
that I don't think that's the message we
want to be putting out there
Society
I actually used to like sex but now all
we told God that's all he wants to talk
about I'm thinking why because guys want
to have sex if you were 300 pounds guys
wouldn't talk to you no but that no but
the point is the point is a lot of women
just want to talk have conversation all
men want to do nowadays is suck it guys
that don't like you
like that's all they want to do guys
that don't like you just want to have
sex yeah but you can like me and don't
just talk to me well yeah he probably
doesn't he probably doesn't like you if
he doesn't want to talk to you no no but
what I'm saying is you I know you like
me right but why is it that you know you
want to have sex all the time it's it's
actually annoying
yeah I mean because they're they're guys
you know this is this is why some some
like the hardcore feminist types that's
part of why they make themselves
unattractive
what do you mean to not get as much male
attention right they they literally will
make themselves whether it's through
their haircut the way they dress how
many pounds they weigh or whatever they
will make themselves less physically
desirable
consciously or subconsciously in order
to have less men approaching them and
dealing with them which is
a bit of a sidebar but it's an
interesting point compared to just given
what you were saying yeah yeah okay yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna take a second to
read super chats um then I think we're
gonna close out the show so if you have
any final thoughts you want to like
speak your piece on
um you know feel free so um 67 Big Mel
love the show Anthony Guzman interesting
to interesting you got to touch this
topic I would love to hear more of this
um daffwool101 in Australia there's a
small group of adults who are trying to
tell people they now identify as
children and have the right to sleep
with children every point that the lady
is talking about transgender these
adults are saying too what if that was
about your child Johnny B forget the
physical differences should men be
allowed to take advantage of women only
school and government programs um hi
Keith though helgura I'm gay is a
preference you can like chocolate or
oatmeal cookies trans culture wants you
to accept that oatmeal candy chocolate
and vice versa yes all based on feelings
j b f m 101 it when her real viewpoints
came out and she quickly changes this
girl is the definition of she babes go
think for yourself and then come back
Auntie Jenny I'm sorry we can't save her
Matt butcher Rapunzel I figured you out
you're trolling us and you're killing it
girl there has to be an award for this
oh wait let me refresh this so I can see
the news
yeah no no sorry I realize I didn't
refresh the page okay guys make sure you
like the video
um that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these live
so if you like this stream make sure you
like it because a like is free and all
the super chats are going towards an 8K
camera okay mgtow by Logic you're
awesome Tallulah keep it up Alistar
Horton men mostly look for sex men look
mostly for sex from women because it is
one of the few things the independent
man most women want can't get on their
own mgtow by Logic I can't a king once
did acts Ergo all men are trash also my
dad was trash so all men are trash low
value women
um Gabrielle Gabrielle Turman 50 50 is
confusing blame and effort it takes
equal effort but women have so much
opportunity of choice just don't pick
the guy who leaves and don't pick the
guy you know will leave Daniel Cole I
make 20 hours I I make 20 hours and pay
1500 a month in child support why what
is this only Rich guys pay child support
zero Guyer think about it Pearl think
about this Pearl holds two fruits one is
an apple and the other is an orange if
you dip both to be opposite colors can
you call the red painted orange apple
and the orange color Apple orange
Samuel tagin sexual Liberation and birth
control equals single moms villain
eliminating birth control equals no hot
bro Summers otherworldly Oddities TV
Medusa Medusa birth control is not the
same as abortion blackest Panther zubi
uses the same argument women use was
blackest Panther zubi uses the same
argument women use like there aren't
enough women CEOs when only a few men
are actually CEOs in the first place
only a few men impregnate a majority of
women why is zooby placing 50 why is
zoobi placing 50 on men as a whole
Joshua zubi says you shouldn't have kids
with someone you're mortified of
procreating with but women control
access to sex not men mgtow by Logic
women are more responsible because they
make the final choice at choice to Alpha
man or not duh wake up casual hand does
look of the documentary The Vanishing
black family from 18 from 1986 it
explains what happened and where the
single mother crisis pretty much started
JC if the relationship breaks down I
only blame the Man mgtow by Logic
a man doesn't get a woman pregnant she
gets herself pregnant by her own choice
she chooses who goes in not man her body
her choice remember Doug MPA damn zubi
sounding like a simp this hurts 90 free
topic
um for all the men when is the last time
you asked a girl to do anything and she
did it with no Bargains duh the second
you know you can get out of the dishes
you won't do it Matt butcher Rapunzel
please I know you're young please I know
you're young but shut your mouth and
open your ears for a year and just
listen you monopolize the show this is
why we can't have nice things villain
237 shout out to Pearl zubi unte you
guys are great king Zendaya zooby stop
enabling the partnership idea Joseph
Metzler and the U.S women make less
money than men yet hold almost all
credit card debt two-thirds of student
loan debt is held by women same with car
loans men save and invest at a higher
level marriage causes divorce zoobi you
want to get married are you crazy bro
Doug MPA average black woman in the U.S
have a net worth of less than five
dollars have the most Consumer Debt the
most student loan debt highest eviction
rates all of it Wendell coven why do
women feel they get extra points for
being a responsible adult you're you're
an adult that pays the bills will be
Thane
um mtra Auntie keep cooking these young
delusional children we love you Das
token E30 women will never be us we
build we use our hands 93 Tope locks you
proved why women can't be Alpha you
almost ran away because of words there
is no such thing as strong women Jesse
Peterson High Auntie Maury men aren't
looking for for partners by the way in a
heterosexual relationship unleader and
the head of the household as a man my
woman or wife is my son second in
command above our children if we have
any Mar asks both genders are not
entitled to each other's money James
Sharp Pearl your next topic should be
beta males are dangerous because they
enable the toxic behaviors of modern day
women 67 Big male when you remove God
and standards you let the devil in Matt
butcher
Rapunzel you are young and in denial and
showing poor social skills Auntie Pearl
Jess and zubi are being more
accommodating please watch this back and
with an open mind and improve yourself
hater please tell the weak faith that
her faith is most certainly weak she
can't cope when the attention isn't on
her otherworldly Oddities TV you lost
your faith when you went to China your
words Tony as a Christian her faith is
weak it's easier to not follow God
Lawrence I identify as Justin Pearl's
husbands the Sister Wives now now how to
lose yeah oh yeah now how delusional
does that sound
um Tim nurath Pearl Castle coming in hot
let's go Mr missing 44 you got a stage
when you stop thinking exactly the
problem 90 free Tope women are too dumb
for hypotheticals prove me wrong
um Calico loving Jess in that hoodie a
long shot she's making a point you are a
choice you could just ignore what you
didn't recognize or whatever Kane the
the woman really doesn't understand
understand objective reality she keeps
trying to pretend she doesn't grasp
simple Concepts they in some Modern
women are oh no it's a big word some
Modern women have been cat
capitalistically mind as I go have you
seen these words
as economic cogs tax contributors
economic slaves the attempt to divorce
uh the feminine cell from biology is
obscene the plethora of 35 Plus women on
Tick Tock crying is a post-awakening is
now the norm medic braids will always
stay open-minded
braids will stay open-minded till it has
a negative long-term effect in her life
directly Lou Baggins hurt after your
feelings sometimes it's better to be
quiet and let people think you're a fool
than open your mouth and prove them
right Mr missing listening bro when
Caitlyn Jenner won woman of the year
that was a dub for the so-called
patriarchy Maurice anfiog Pearl what in
the world where in the world are you
finding all these second generation
Nigerian women from otherworthly
Oddities TV having a different category
for Trans people still wouldn't work a
woman that's trans to man would still
lose to a man that's trans to woman 67
Big male love the show Anthony Guzman
interesting to see you touch this topic
I would love to hear more of this
dab pool um 101 in Australia there's a
small group of adults who are trying
however this one okay okay
um so thank you guys all for coming good
panel this is fun yeah
yeah see I feel like the craps just make
it better
um so why don't we start on that side
and you can give your final thoughts
anything you want to speak your piece on
go on um and where they can find you
to each to their own really like
everyone has their own opinion that's
all I can say
um we agree to disagree really
um you can find me on Instagram and on
YouTube it is christabel so it dot is
dot Crystal Bell sweet BlackBerry
okay
um what I want to say just listening to
those comments it just shows how
misogynistic our society still is just
because he actually just said it should
be 50 50. like we are still not in that
age where we want to put responsibility
on men and look at the way people are
risk can I make a point there firstly I
think it's interesting that the people
who commented those I noticed all almost
all of their usernames had like um you
know mgtow in there there was a guy who
was had this explicitly anti-marriage
username
um you know so there's certainly a lot
of red pill rage out there and you know
I think it's you know for people who are
deep into the red pill when it goes very
and by the way like uh you know I've
been familiar with this concept since I
was I was a teenager so for all these
people who've just discovered the red
pill recently like you know don't don't
try to school me on this
um it can end up over correcting and
becoming almost like a male version of
the modern feminism that we that we
dislike where Men start having this
victim mentality and wanting to put just
like these feminists are blaming men for
everything and saying the patriarchy you
know as the patriarch it's everything
it's men it's never them men need to be
careful that they don't over correct
into this same mentality of trying to
absolve ourselves of our masculine
duties and responsibilities and overall
ethics and putting all the blame on
women and females I I say the exact same
thing to feminists so I I don't want to
see that over correction in the in the
other direction where it just becomes
this very hard line ideology and and
becomes resentful you know becomes
resentful just like when people go too
deep into feminism they often end up
becoming missandrous and having an
animosity and a resentment towards
towards men it can happen the other way
around when guys go really really deep
especially like the sort of new red pill
stuff and they end up you know being so
deep into the philosophy and ideology
that they're not really thinking of them
themselves individually and there's
people I think it's always been like
that like even if you look at into the
biblical
um time like a woman was not allowed to
be a pastor a woman has to be silent in
the church I think it's always been
where a woman is supposed to be
subordinate and this is what's happening
these comments are just showing
society's reaction to women help me like
sorry help me in the Bible yeah
I know but that's the thing like why is
she this little helper like she's just
supposed to be in the background why
can't she lead why can't she do that I
think again to talk to my point a woman
can a woman can the point is
that that is traditionally a masculine
role and this often comes down to what
both each each gender is attracted to as
I said before a woman can have that
position and want to roll and even want
to be the breadwinner and so on and so
forth
and she can find a guy who will be happy
with that and will be happy to assume
that position I'm just saying that's
going to be a more feminized man
I mean
I'm just that's just the reality of it
because you're you're going to get the
complementary aspect so yeah if a man is
very very masculine in a traditional
sense he's likely to attract and be
compatible with a very very feminine
woman if a woman is coming in playing
more the traditional masculine role then
a man who wants to also play that
traditional masculine they're they're
gonna Clash they're not they're not
going to get along well with each other
and I think to me that's always been the
problem because I'm a leader like I like
to lead in a relationship but I also
like my Manta lead no
I'm just saying what I'm trying to say
exactly because people keep saying it's
not going to work
let me tell you something it's not just
it's not just in our head it's in our
biological wiring it's in our Instinct
so just like you are are you do you
prefer taller man
okay right so just like that's hardwired
and you biologically even if you wanted
to like force yourself to try to be more
attracted to men shorter than you and
you can't biologically it's the same as
a man in wanting to
play a certain role in a relationship
and to be a leader to an extent it's
hardwired in us it's not just a societal
opinion allow me you don't allow me to
have certain control of certain aspects
in the relationship I'm already turned
off anyway I could be so attracted to
you and as soon as you're like I've got
to control the finances I've got to do
this I'm like you know what boy I feel
like you just want the best of
everything
why why can't I why can't why can't I
have okay why can't men have pure
virgins
I'm saying like like women bring less to
the table than ever we're less pure
we're older when we get married and so
it's like you don't see zooby on this
panel saying like why why isn't everyone
22. like
and so and so it's like
like you just want everything
yeah I do yeah yeah
minority rights
I am a walking people naturally hate me
because I'm so against what Society is
no I think people if a woman can do it
all I think I think it's because you're
argumentative I don't think it's because
you're against what Society is I think
the backlash you get is because you're
argumentative and you interrupt not
nothing to do with it
again
I think you're actually a very
compassionate person
but I think that that compassion is
sometimes blinding you to certain
realities I'd also just think you're
young right I'm not trying to be this
patronizing person right but when as as
you get older some of the things will
right even between the a for me between
the ages of 25 and 35 the way certain
things that like my parents used to say
or that I used to hear the way some of
it started like clicking and I was like
oh okay that that's why it was like that
or you know you just experienced 10 more
years of life and you interact with
thousands and thousands of more people
and you see no okay that's why certain
things are certain ways it's not just
because people are mean and nasty and
want to like press down on women or no
it's because men don't want to accept
that women we can make our own money we
know you can we can build we don't need
your money so why do you like so why do
you even want to get married you said
you want to get married why because I
love men I actually like me why I get
married you know what but actually this
is a point I've always been wanting to
make I've come to realize that men don't
actually like women that's not true they
they just see us
all you see us is for sex no if you
respected us is this how I've come
across in the past three years
I mean that's what you're getting hate
though that's why you're getting hate
because
I'm mostly getting love I'm just saying
I think there's a couple guys in the
chat who have what I call Red Pill rage
yeah but as soon as you start talking
about the balance that was rage because
that's because I do think men just see
us as sex objects we generally they
don't respect us I don't think men
respects us they they respect their
other fellow men they see a man and
think oh he's strong yeah you can do
this to see a woman
I think if I were I think if I were
making a statement that Broad and
generalized about women you wouldn't
like it would you say do you have
brothers do you have cousins boy cousins
yeah is your father still in your life
yeah okay
would you say that there since you're
clumping all of them together you say
they're they just want females like I
will say that because a lot of time I
will have to even check my brother to
say why are you not allowing her to make
a decision it's her life I will check
men even if I love you I also have to
understand that women need to be
respected it's not happening we look at
that women do you check women for not
being the things that men want do you
know some girls like being a hoe will
you check her yeah yeah yeah as much as
I check men so when she was talking
about the story about the woman that had
had 16 kids and the man that has 16 kids
to me both of them hoes I don't see her
as a whole no I'm sorry both of them
need to be held responsibly like
responsible and I think that's what's
not happening we keep slut-shaming women
but a man is you know he's a gallist you
know women love him we're not putting
responsibilities on men and I think it's
a problem I think that men have all the
response ability again like men pay for
everything every decision
I don't think they should but I'm saying
like we're not putting any of the
responsibility I'm saying we're not
putting any of the responsibility you're
saying we're not putting the
responsibility on men I'm saying they
have all of it because there's a
consequence when they do something
there's not for women so if anything you
could argue it more the other way around
do you know what I think is is really
really confusing with this point where
we are right now in modern society is
people really want to have the cake and
eat it too people want to be traditional
take to kind of cherry pick some of the
traditional elements and the gender
roles and then completely have like this
equally total equality view in other
places and kind of cherry pick from all
these things and these things don't they
don't work they don't work together they
don't they don't work in harmony you
can't have like all of it right if it's
like okay we're gonna just treat men and
women exactly the same with very few
accommodations no special treatment and
so on we're not going to have chivalry
and you know men and women women and men
women and children get off the get off
the boat the sinking boat first right
you you can't in a truly equalist
Society you can't have those
accommodations but I do already agree
with that yeah yeah I think man if he
says I don't want to propose to you babe
yeah I understand because you know what
reasons are expensive yeah
you know what I mean I already think but
the reality is that men and women due to
our biology were still wired to be
attracted to the same things that our
ancestors were so even though so
generally speaking even though yes women
women can make money in fact under the
age of 30 in most cases in many Western
countries now women actually out earn
men on average right it's not until they
get into their 30s and oftentimes start
families that it switches because
they're the ones who have get pregnant
and breastfeed and so on it makes sense
um
but where where was I going with this
um
I lost my I lost my train of thought
there it's a little lit a little bit
late we want to see okay can have it
yeah yeah they don't the these these
things are not they're not compatible
they're they're not compatible you can't
be on one hand saying strong independent
woman got my own money whatever oh but
also I still want the man to be taller
and make even more money than I do and
to lead but I also want to lead and I
want it it just doesn't it contradicts
too much I agree it contradicts too much
where can they find you yeah
on Instagram
esther.o Yeti underscore do Follow Me
I'm Actually lovely she actually had a
very funny episode with castella I
actually really liked that video it was
really good
um you guys should check it out on
YouTube too
Auntie on Guinea
bring on tradition
save the world with tradition
and we're starting your channel soon
yeah so you can find me yeah it'll
you'll you'll see guys you'll see I'll
post it go ahead I don't have any more
final thoughts I'm just kind of
resounding of whatever everyone should
say
um but what I will do is plug my
Instagram
um to go back to my initial statement of
me putting my foot on my head perhaps
portal so my Instagram is Emily Emilia
Rose that's my final thought for the
evening
um just you want to go and then see if
we can go yeah
um
great panel I love going back and forth
to people it's it's fun so just the
intense conversations I enjoy it enjoy
seeing people's uh
uh differences in understanding
where they come from I think everybody
should be able to
do that in any setting that they're in
[Music]
um
where you can find me you can find me on
Instagram and YouTube at uh your girl
justly
both of them coincide Pearl you'd be
happy yeah
awesome and thank you for coming by the
way you're welcome I've been following
zoobie for a minute so I was really
excited to have you on no it's it's been
an honor thank you Pro for hosting it
thank you for everyone who's been a part
of this I I think this has genuinely
been a very positive discussion I think
these conversations are very very
necessary in society and we should all
be having more of them and where people
can find me I'm on all social media at
zooby music z-u-b-y music check out
teamzubi.com we just launched the new
website and you can follow me everywhere
you can find my podcast on all platforms
real talk with zoobie you can find my
music on iTunes Apple music Spotify all
the usual places just search my name
zubi and you will find me
okay guys um a couple announcements
before we end the show don't forget to
subscribe to the channel as you already
know if you've watched two or more lives
and you don't subscribe we have beef so
hit that subscribe button like the video
on your way out also follow our two
clips Channel Sign up for our
memberships if you want to be part of
the chat next show
um if you want to see what the penthouse
looks like sign up for our 10
memberships and our third membership you
connect with us on social media fourth
membership it's a one-on-one call with
me once a month DM Eddie if you want to
get on the show the link to his
Instagram is in the description thank
you guys for watching and we will talk
to you next time as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible